bonjour alors il y a cinq ans une amie
m'a alerté sur les dangers des
chemtrails les chemtrails vous savez ce
sont ces traînées blanches qu'on voit
dans le ciel dans le sillage des avions
c'était selon elle des substances
toxiques répandu pour nous empoisonner
tu as des preuves
lui ai je demandé des preuves
irréfutables mattel affirmé j'ai vu des
photos et des vidéos sur internet
sa réponse m'a inquiété d'autant que
durant la même période
d'autres amis publier d'autres rumeurs
canular et autres bobards sur mon mur
facebook
mon sentiment de malaise et est d'autant
plus désagréable que en parallèle je
constatais que de plus en plus
d'écoliers surfer sur internet
comment allait-il faire pour se repérer
dans cet océan d'imagés de textes
voilà pourquoi j'ai créé un scénario
pédagogique pour eux j'ai créé ce projet
pour leur apprendre à faire la
différence entre l'info et l'intox sur
internet et les réseaux sociaux et ce
dès l'école primaire
alors je me suis fixé deux objectifs
aiguiser leur esprit critique pour
qu'ils ne se fassent pas manipuler et
les aider à devenir des cyber citoyens
qu'ils fassent barrage aux idées
racistes et haineuses et complotistes
j'ai expérimenté cet atelier d'éducation
aux médias durant quatre années dans une
école primaire à taninges en haute
savoie
à raison d'une séance par semaine tout
au long de l'année
alors pourquoi avoir créé ce genre
d'atelier pour des élèves aussi jeune et
bien pour leur donner des outils
d'autodéfense intellectuelle avant qu'il
n'aborde l'adolescence
un âge particulièrement vulnérables où
ils risquent de ceux d'être tenté par le
chant des sirènes de manipulateur en
tout genre à la fin de l'année scolaire
les élèves reçoivent un diplôme
d'apprenti hoaxbuster c'est-à-dire un
diplôme de traqueurs de fausses
informations dans une cérémonie au cours
de laquelle il prête serment sur la tête
de la souris de leur ordinateur avant
d'utiliser ou de transmettre une
information toujours jeu-là vérifierait
des vidéos présentant mon projet sont en
ligne sur la chaîne youtube une hygiène
mentale une excellente chaîne dédiée
l'ex à l'esprit critique vous allez voir
un extrait d'une vidéo dans laquelle on
voit les élèves à l'oeuvre en train
d'analyser une photo qu'il n'avait
jamais observée auparavant
une photo qui avait circulé pendant
l'euro 2007
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette image
toute récente parce que on
[Musique]
c'est parfait tu sais que un journaliste
de faire avoir être là j'ai absolument
je te prie citoyen du premier coup c'est
la première fois qu'ils ont trouvé tout
de suite
moi je sais pas si j'aurais surtout
aussi là là c'est carrément la chambre
l'avoir ici là qu'il a la main derrière
que la faim ici à menou will apparemment
seuls les survenants ce bail serait
romeu niveau plaisir par un peu sourds
entre les gens ouais il pas y passera la
fin
alors maintenant comment se déroulement
scénario première étape pour reconnaître
une fausse information il faut d'abord
comprendre ce qui est une vraie info
observer la différence entre publicité
et rédactionnelles explorer les
différents médias et le métier de
journaliste alors pour se faire une idée
du métier de journaliste rien de tel que
de rédiger soi même des articles et
aussi de d'interviewer des journalistes
mais pour comprendre la difficulté de
transcrire la réalité qui est complexe
les élèves abordent les notion
d'objectivité de subjectivité à travers
des jeux de rôle alors certains élèves
se mettre dans la peau de journalistes
d'autres dans la peau des personnes
interviewées et il réalise que les
témoignages peuvent être contradictoires
souvent d'ailleurs exemple un accident
de voiture dans le centre du village un
mort deux blessés selon un policier
mais un témoin a vu trois morts il y
avait du sang partout il n'en démord pas
qui croire est ce que tous les
témoignages ont la même fiabilité les
élèves constate ainsi l'importance de
recueillir les différents points de vue
des protagonistes impliqués dans un
événement pour avoir des éclairages
différents de la réalité mais également
l'importance de faire la différence
entre une opinion est en fait que l'on
peut prouver
autre exemple d'un pro une manifestation
contre la chasse la manif est un succès
selon les uns et un échec selon les
autres là encore qui croire et que
penser d'un journaliste qui ne
rapporterait que qu'un seul point de vue
et si ce journaliste est lui-même
chasseur ou écologistes est-il facile
pour lui d'être objectif et d'ailleurs
est ce que l'objectivité existe surtout
sachant que nous avons tous tendance à
ne nous intéresser à écouter à ne
partage et que les informations qui vont
danse
de nos opinions un travers qui s'appelle
le biais de confirmation les élèves
réalisent ainsi que la faiblesse de
notre psychisme
c'est important de comprendre qu'on peut
se faire manipuler par autrui de manière
intentionnelle ou pas d'ailleurs
mais on peut se faire manipuler par nous
mêmes on peut se faire berner par nous
mêmes par notre cerveau qui nous joue
des tours avec des des préjugés des des
illusions d'optique des corrélations
illusoire avec tout un tas de deux biais
cognitifs
il y en a plus de 150 à 200 biais
cognitifs qui sont recensés
distanciation esprit critique sont
nécessaires pour aborder une information
et se forger sa propre opinion mais
l'esprit critique est d'autant plus
important sur internet que n'importe qui
peut publier n'importe quoi sans être
soumis à aucune règle déontologique dans
une deuxième étape
les élèves se transforment en petits
détectives du web pour mener leurs
investigations ils découvrent le
fonctionnement des moteurs de recherche
il dit c'est les contenus il décortique
les informations il remonte jusqu'à la
source de l'information en identifiant
qui a écrit l'article sur quel site
à quelle date est ce un site
d'informations fiables est ce un site
dans lequel travail des journalistes
professionnels as un site parodique où
est-ce un site plus ou moins douteux
coutumier des fausses informations
fausses informations qu'on appelle un
fox maintenant puis il applique une
stratégie croiser les informations sur
plusieurs médias fiable écartée celle en
provenance de médias non fiables et si
l'information provient d'un site fiable
et que le journal est reconnu à quoi bon
croiser l information un élève à vous
répondre je si je connais le journal
d'où est extrait l'information j'ai pas
besoin de vérifier puisque je connais
mon journal et bah si tout le monde peut
se tromper
lego journalistes peuvent se trouver
quand il faut croiser l'information
allez voir sur d'autres sites fiables
outre l'importance des sources
les élèves découvrent l'importance de la
contextualisations des textes des images
on peut modifier une image de mille et
une manières peu la manipuler avec la
technique avec des outils comme
photoshop mais rien qu'avec le choix du
cadrage on peut modifier le message
voici comment j'aborde la notion de
cadrage avec une photo de maîtresse
isabelle en train de découper un gros
gâteau avec un gros couteau en piscine
on photo cadrer avec deux cadrages
différents donc j'aimerais bien avoir
vos réactions c'est bien pour les
personnes qui savent pas c'est marrant
mais si par exemple quelqu'un le prend
mal
c'est vraiment ça peut être que ça peut
tomber en terrestre à ça peut provoquer
mme kaba voilà oui si tu utilises cette
photo si je prends cette photo et que je
la mets sur internet la première photo
qu'est ce qui risque de se passer
eh bien ils vont dire haut et 7 litres
est ce n est pas bien il faut prélever
de cette école et tout ça ils vont le
dire
des méchants c'est aussi sur elle la
première sur internet après avoir une
rumeur oui on peut dire à l'honneur
chaque rumeur elle dirait quoi
mais pourquoi elle swaps à cinq ans
parce qu'elles coupent les doigts des
enfants tous leurs camarades
on voit passer moi on peut par un petit
gâteau celle ci doit
mais verizon sur l'amour sur internet
ok après on croit que c'est vrai on
allait porter plainte et simple qui
pourrait porter plainte justement qui va
porter plainte si on met cette si moi je
mets cette photo sur internet qui va
porter plainte
les gens les gens qui rejoignent qu'ils
aient les gens qui la voient ils
porteront plainte les neuf il croit que
les parents d'élèves qui vont porter
plainte
réfléchissez qui peut parfaitement ne
manque évidemment pas la maîtresse oui
je pense que c'est plutôt la maîtresse
qui part très plat parce que qu'est-ce
que ça lui ferait comme réputation c1
ça lui nuirait à sa réputation après on
dirait quoi
partout en france en inde roms sont
acceptés dans un travail précieux aux
fausses notes la wii on peut mentir sur
la légende d'une photo on peut mentir
sur l'histoire de cette photo qui l'a
prise où quand comment pourquoi
d'où l'intérêt de savoir analyser les
détails d'une image est de savoir
utiliser des doutes des outils comme
google maps et street view pour repérer
où la photo a été prise et de savoir
utiliser des outils comme google images
outin haye pour retracer les origines et
le parcours d'une image sur la toile
voici une petite démo d'une avec un
élève qui va vous des banques et cette
photo
[Musique]
au fait pourquoi je dis que a été fait
en scène pendant la guerre
pendant la guerre est en fait ce n'est
pas du tout mais c'était en australie en
forme de crâne et cette dame avoir votre
avis on utilise des images d'enfants
dans des films des photos pour que ça
fasse encore plus pitié que les gens
buybox c'est encore pire si c'est les
enfants des adultes
donc on veut toucher quoi il est claire
le coeur bien alors on fait clic droit
sur copier l'adresse de l'image moi
c'est fait maintenant on va dans un
nouvel angle ai marre google images on
assure le shit
on l'a sur un petit recherché par
l'image on sait qu'entre lui et vous
fait rechercher par image et ça nous
amène là bravo
alors pour chaque fausse information
repérer on se demande toujours pourquoi
elle a été diffusée alors on ne peut
émettre que des hypothèses
donc est ce que c'est pour faire rire
est ce que c'est pour gagner de l'argent
pour faire des clips pour faire du buzz
pour faire de la pub est ce que c'est
par négligence souvent aussi est ce que
c'est pour convaincre ou alors est ce
que c'est pour nuire les élèves constate
que les internautes diffusant des
fausses d'information ont tendance à
jouer sur le registre du sensationnel de
l'émotionnel pour susciter la peur la
pitié la haine pour capter l'attention
pas étonnant du coup que les fausses
informations circulent six fois plus
vite que les vrais dixit une étude du
hem haïti de mars 2016 2018 en fin
d'année nous consacrons aussi du temps
pour réfléchir comment réagir au contenu
haineux qu'est ce que peut être la cyber
citoyenneté et comment concilier cyber
citoyenneté liberté d'expression alors
maintenant le bilan de ce projet
chaque année les élèves s'investissent à
fond dans toutes les activités proposées
chaque année je suis bluffé par la
pertinence de leurs remarques et de
leurs questions comme des grands ils
raisonnent
ils débattent ils argumentent ils créent
des contenus il crée des articles si un
journal il crée des vidéos
il crée des îles font des reportages
photos d'anne argileux plus beaux
villages de france
d'un âge et le plus les villages de
france sans montage et puis aussi il
crée des posteurs une exposition
virtuelle de poster en fin d'année avec
des conseils pour surfer sur internet
alors premier conseil qui va apparaître
il faut penser à croiser les
informations sur plusieurs sites
il ya aussi une autre
un autre dessin voilà penser à croiser
les informations on retrouve la petite
fille à la boue couvre couverte de boue
sur le monde ou sur internet
pensez à aller dans les mentions
mentions légales qui sommes nous à
propos pour vérifier l'identité enquêter
sur l'identité du site que vous visitez
pensez à utiliser google images dont
voici le mode d'emploi
méfiez-vous des sites complotistes pensé
à utiliser des codex un outil créé par
les décodeurs du monde pour vérifier la
fiabilité des sites d'information et
voilà là c'était penser à ne pas tomber
dans le panneau des sites parodiques
comme le gora fille et puis cette
dernière ce dernier dessin que je
voulais vous montrer parce que c'est mon
préféré qui va arriver qui est faisons
tous barrage aux fausses d'information
devenons tous des chasseurs de fausses
d'information comme ceux hoaxbuster qui
fait barrage de son corps à une rumeur à
tête d'illuminati
[Applaudissements]